There’s a hole in the sun!!!
But no need to panic….unless you play Pokemon
Go...
Hello fellow sun-worshipers!
Ian here for DNews and I have a twisted story
of magnetic solar drama to tell.
Now, you may have seen this video of the sun
from last week.
It’s an observation taken by NASA’s Solar
Dynamics Observatory, or SDO, and it shows
the superheated solar atmosphere, or the corona.
But you see that big, scary dark patch that
looks like a hole?
That is the thing that may affect your Pokemon
mojo… but more on that later.
First, let’s get to grips with what’s
happening deep in the sun’s atmosphere..
So the cool thing about the solar corona is
that it is a highly magnetic region surrounding
the sun.
Huge arcs of magnetism erupt from the sun’s
interior, trapping the sun’s ionized gases
-- called plasma.
Through magnetic processes, this trapped plasma
is heated to crazy high temperatures to well
over a million degrees Celsius.
So, what’s this “hole” all about?
Well, if you look at this SDO observation
of the sun, you can see the corona is filled
with beautiful bright loops of plasma trapped
in magnetism.
These are known as coronal loops and they
are closed magnetic fields.
Because they are closed, plasma is trapped
and heated, causing them to shine brightly
in extreme ultraviolet wavelengths.
But often, these closed field lines give way
to “open” field lines -- basically regions
of magnetism that project from deep within
the sun, through the sun’s outer layers,
reaching out through the corona and far out
into the solar system.
The sun’s plasma will use these open field
lines as a guide, blasting out into interplanetary
space like a firehose.
These open field lines are the source of the
fast solar wind and as the sun rotates, these
“coronal holes,” as they are known, will
blast a stream of high-speed plasma through
Earth’s orbit.
When observing the sun in ultraviolet wavelengths,
we see these coronal holes as dark patches
surrounded by bright coronal loops.
Currently the sun is in a lull of activity,
approaching the solar minimum of its 11 year
cycle.
At solar minimum, the sun’s magnetic field
becomes less chaotic, so when these coronal
holes form, they can look pretty big and dramatic.
Now I know what you’re thinking: when is
he going to tell me about how this affects
me catching Pokemon??!!
As I mentioned, coronal holes are a source
of the fast solar wind.
These high intensity streams boost the radiation
environment surrounding Earth and, if the
conditions are right, auroral activity can
intensify even when the sun is pretty quiet.
Auroras form at high latitudes when solar
wind particles rain through the upper atmosphere,
causing atmospheric gases to glow.
These geomagnetic storms can create global
electric currents that could overload national
power grids.
Though unlikely, solar storms could even impact
satellites -- knocking out GPS and messing
with your search for Pokemon.
Solar flares and coronal mass ejections can
also cause global radio outages, possibly
impacting air traffic control.
Astronauts in orbit will also need to be extra
careful to avoid exposure to these radiation
hazards.
So yes, the sun can impact our everyday, high-tech
lives, but in this case the sun’s coronal
hole looks way more dramatic than it really
is.
Want to know more about the mischief our nearest
star can cause to Earth, check out Trace and
Julian’s cool video about solar doom!
Do
you find space weather scary?
Let us know in the comments down below and
don’t forget to subscribe to DNews!